Tom Curren joining us now how's morale
in New England there Tommy just like
everybody was when Clint walked oh yeah
you know in the Boston New England
region I think fans are resigned
suddenly to the fact well we're not good
anymore but I think within the locker
room at least and I don't know if this
is naive on their parts or not the
Patriots are taking solace in the fact
that they feel is this look the games
that we've lost especially the last two
weeks it's not them it's us we're
committing the penalties we're having
the key drops so they're taking solace
in the idea that look it's we can fix
this it's not a it's a big deal but not
a huge deal do you think Brady cares
being selected to the Pro Bowl no I
don't and I think that he probably would
say I've not been a Pro Bowl quarterback
this year because he has been so
markedly inferior to the level of play
that he's put out there he's been an OK
quarterback this year what's the reason
I think it's a variety of them but if
you went chronologically if we spend 17
or 18 years talking about how important
the offseason program is in the
offseason time that he spends where he
goes to Montana and he throws to Edelman
and Amendola and he is tireless in
workouts if you skip that entirely
almost and the team is actually going
through a period where they're trying to
get new guys assimilated and you move
Brandon cooks out Rob Gronkowski's hurt
and Julian Edelman dismisses the first
four games all of that stuff puts him so
far behind where he normally is and I
don't I really don't think it's
age-related and I don't think it's
physical I think it's that confluence of
circumstances he put less time in the
offseason and they actually went through
a pretty significant offensive
renovation did they overeat Grunk and
and what his importance or his role was
going to be with this team this year
no and the reason I say that
because they tried to treat him in April
yeah if they felt comfortable with where
he was going to be in 2018 they wouldn't
have tried to trade him and I disagreed
with the idea that you should try to
trade him based upon what he did in 2017
he was the best tight end in football by
a lot and I think people probably
conveniently forget because we are hey
the last thing that I saw a type of
society right now but Gronkowski was
outstanding in 2017 but him being away
from the off season program as well
didn't help him and he played ok in the
beginning but once he got dinged it
became the same thing and it also is
it's always a mental thing with him too
because he's gone through so many
injuries as to how confident he is when
he's on the field would you be surprised
that he's playing next year I'd be
stunned if he's playing here I would be
surprised if he's playing yeah I guess I
would be surprised if he's playing
anywhere then because he says if I'm not
playing with Don I'm not playing so it's
been again it's two years in a row it's
not a lot of fun in terms of football
for for Gronk first it was off the field
and then this year I think it's on the
field and off the field I mean there's
no way he's gonna hit those incentives
he feels as if he got hoes on those so
it's been not a great experience for him
but I just don't think at 30 as much as
you might think I'm ready to go on to
the next chapter it's tough to get your
mind around what actually the next
chapter is at 30 when you've done
nothing but this if you were going to in
order of greatness where did the
Patriots rank right now in the pecking
order of teams going into the final two
weeks here I'd say they're probably
third or fourth in the AFC you have to
say Kansas City's better San Diego
certainly better other teams have played
better Houston even though the Patriots
beat them is nothing like the team the
Patriots beat in the opener so I would
say if you base it on what they are
endemic or he said that to me this week
like quick slants the television show
and podcast there this is what we are
you know we we we earned our 9 and 5 we
are a 5 loss team they all came on the
road you know it's been one thing or
another and to me what's been most
surprising is
seeming not declined but new issues are
popping up in December which is unusual
if I said you had to take one or the
other that the Patriots more likely go
to the Super Bowl or lose their
first-round playoff game Wow
any hypothetical just continuing to come
off the table at me I would say lose
their first playoff game I don't see
them stringing together I don't see them
stringing together two consecutive wins
the second one on the road I mean no
it's because no yeah they it was the
first one because if they they just have
not proven that they're a very good road
team this year yeah and even watching
them against Pittsburgh like I keep
waiting for something magical to happen
and it's just not gonna be there they
they're they're just they don't have
that makeup to make magic like they used
to so I don't know if there's a switch
that great teams do that they flip on
but it just doesn't feel like it's there
no matter how far they survived it just
doesn't feel like they're that much of a
threat the way they they have been in
the last 15 years would you have felt
that way though had Shaq Mason not
gotten calls for a hold on Sony Michelle
down to or whatever it was and they go
in and they tie the game then it's and
I'm not saying that was about to happen
but there were details within the game
that they were on the cusp of the
threshold of the brink of doing some
wait wait did they were on the cusp of
the threshold of drink-drink okay Wow
doing something that made you gob well
same old Patriots and that's why it's
dangerous to go too far one way or the
other I think in saying they're
completely dead they're never the same
they should just blow it up and Robert
Kraft should sell I just it's not no no
no this isn't first taken those shows
that we don't I'm not doing that they're
not dead I just don't yeah
but but I I look at them I just don't
think they're threatening and you know
we're making a big deal okay they could
have they could have tied Pittsburgh or
beaten Pittsburgh good pick Pittsburgh's
not a good team no they're not they're
more dangerous than New England is I
believe about that one I don't think
they lost Oakland there I mean but when
you were Pittsburgh they're gonna say
holy crap we gave up the only touchdown
we gave up to those idiots was when we
all covered Josh Gordon left Julian
Edelman by himself so they're gonna have
that isn't that their mind all of these
teams can look at this and say they all
can look at each other and say that team
doesn't impress me and I was talking to
Tom Brady in the locker room this week
and he said look I'm not afraid of any
team we're not afraid of any team yeah
but what did shock you it would shock me
if he said you know we're afraid of a
couple of teams here I mean when tradies
ever been shocked you know scared of
anybody I don't think well I guess the
more interesting thing would be if any
teams are afraid of the Patriots anymore
but I mean he that was just he and I
kind of talking on the side he wasn't
saying that's the podium so I mean he
really thinks that everything the
Patriots are convinced that everything
is within their control to fix and it's
just a matter of doing so so that I
think would be the one caveat to the
conversation of whether they're dead or
not all right you have to what are you
trying to get rid of me now no no I'm
just gonna speed it up like you know
that you're you know you were kind of
struggling there and to give me
something so I did moving on trying to
help you Tom okay you have to pick the
representative from the AFC in the Super
Bowl right now hypothetically
hypothetical Dan it's the Kansas City
Chiefs and they couldn't be happier
who couldn't be happier the Chiefs oh
well yeah why wait
well that that you're backing them
that's where they couldn't be happier
they couldn't be happier that they're
there you were speaking me into the
future so I did that you said the the
representative ease and I said it's the
Chiefs and they couldn't be happy okay
oh there he'll do me a favor too
actually any of you you could Danette
okay convince me that Pat mahomes is not
the MVP because I got to do one of those
votes I think you do too
he's the MVP but my point is whoever
wins the AFC West which which
quarterback wins the AFC West I believe
will be the MVP
I think Phillip Rivers is an equally
good story and the writers love a good
story
mahomes is the MVP I don't put drew
brees in there it's a yes mclovin won
I mean the home is obviously a system
quarterback everyone knows that and
indeed how many Pro Bowl I mean Annie
Reed could turn out Smith into a Pro
Bowler Wow all right so if we turn now
let's listen to a Pro Bowler
McLovin he just turned this guy into the
MVP Paulie made me say hey Tom I don't
really believe that hypothetical I think
mahomes is your MVP I think it's between
mahomes and Phillip Rivers and I was
just saying look if you have a
tiebreaker whoever wins the AFC West I
would have no problem with either one of
those guys but I think mahomes should be
honored by the writers broadcasters for
what he's done this year it's been an
incredible performance and they you know
some people had them third or fourth in
the West believe it or not starting this
season so they've been a pleasant
surprise guy says to me the other day
I've known you you're busy you get a
rapid he's going three in big games okay
so it's 51 against the Rams 42 against
the Patriots and it's not his fault they
went to San Diego all right that's it
but thank you Tom very good
hypothetically I'd like to say have a
Merry Christmas for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
at
you
[Music]